the security council heard two very
different arguments about the situation
in eastern europe the u.s which called
this meeting says the russian military
buildup around ukraine is the largest
mobilization of troops in europe in
decades
russia's aggression today not only
threaten ukraine
it also threatens europe
it threatens the international order
this body is charged with upholding
we continue to hope russia chooses the
path of diplomacy
over the path of conflict in ukraine
but we cannot just wait and see
but russia's ambassador vasily nabenzia
says all his country's troops are on
russian soil they're not close to the
ukrainian border and there's absolutely
no proof of a threat from them he says
the us and nato were whipping up
tensions as though they want there to be
a war
outside the council chamber i pushed him
further on this are there any
circumstances in which russian troops
would cross the border into ukraine can
you just be clear for us
i'm
not the person to decide whatever
happens but we never i said it in my
statement that no russian politician
or even a public figure ever said that
we are planning to attack ukraine
a clear answer it seemed but then he
added this we do not exclude
provocations from
from ukraine inside and the
separatist republics they say they have
information that such provocations
may happen
russia had tried to prevent this meeting
by calling a procedural vote at the
start
nine countries supported the us but
russia was joined by china in objecting
to the session and three other security
council members gabon kenya and india
abstained
the meeting went ahead but the
procedural vote and the comments of many
of the non-western members of the
council should be noted the us's aim
here was to galvanize international
opinion against what it says is the
russian threat but to achieve a broad
international consensus it still has
more work to do james bays al jazeera at
the united nations